- WITH OUR SIGN NOW ON DISPLAY,
MY PLAN QUICKLY BEGAN TO WORK,
AS PEOPLE STARTED COMING IN
THINKING IT WAS
AN ACTUAL STARBUCKS.
- OH, DUMB STARBUCKS.
OKAY, OKAY.
- OH, YOU THOUGHT
IT WAS STARBUCKS.
- I DID.
- BUT THE FEW CUSTOMERS WE DID
GET SEEMED TO HAVE TROUBLE
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WE WERE
ALL ABOUT.
I MEAN, LEGALLY SPEAKING,
THIS STORE HAS TO BE CATEGORIZED
AS AN ART GALLERY,
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO ABIDE
BY THE SAME HEALTH REGULATIONS
AS A STARBUCKS WOULD.
I MEAN, WE DON'T WANT ANY OF
OUR CUSTOMERS TO GET SICK.
BUT IF THEY DO,
TECHNICALLY,
THAT'S PART OF
THE ARTISTIC EXPERIENCE.
THINGS WERE OFF
TO AN OKAY START.
BUT AS THE DAY PROGRESSED,
I BECAME FRUSTRATED
WE WEREN'T GETTING THE AMOUNT
OF CUSTOMERS I EXPECTED.
SO I HEADED OUT TO A NEARBY
COFFEE SHOP
TO TRY AND SPREAD THE WORD
ABOUT MY NEW BUSINESS.
JUST SO YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A DUMB STARBUCKS
THAT'S OPENED UP
DOWN THE BLOCK.
- OKAY.
IT'S BASICALLY THE SAME COFFEE.
CHEAPER PRICES, AND--
- DUMB STARBUCKS?
- YEAH.
TODAY, YOU KNOW, YOU CAN HAVE
A FREE COFFEE ON ME.
- I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE TRYING
TO PROMOTE YOUR COMPANY.
- RIGHT.
- I ADMIRE THAT.
BUT THAT'S GREAT.
YOU CAN'T DO IT ON
STARBUCKS' PROPERTY.
- AND I ADMIRE YOU.
AND I WILL BE--
- AND EVERY TIME I STEP BACK,
YOU KEEP TAKING A STEP FORWARD.
- NO, I HAVEN'T MOVED.
- YOU HAVE.
WE STARTED OVER HERE.
- NO, WE STARTED RIGHT HERE.
- BUT YOU NEED TO WALK THAT WAY.
- OKAY, I WILL.
- UNFORTUNATELY, MY MARKETING
EFFORTS WERE CUT SHORT.
BUT I WAS AT LEAST ABLE
TO GET SOME FREE SUPPLIES.
WITH AN UNDERWHELMING
LAUNCH DAY,
I BEGAN TO FEEL LIKE I PUT IN
ALL THIS EFFORT FOR NOTHING.
BUT THE NEXT MORNING
THINGS CHANGED.
JEREMIAH CALLED ME TO SAY
THERE WAS A LINE
OF OVER 15 PEOPLE AT THE STORE.
THEN I SAW PHOTOS
OF MY SHOP POSTED
ON A STRAIGHT BODY BUILDING
MESSAGE BOARD.
BUT I COULDN'T HAVE FORESEEN
WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
- A NEW COFFEE SHOP
WITH A FAMILIAR NAME
CREATING QUITE A STIR
IN LOS ANGELES.
THE COFFEE SHOP--GET THIS--
IS CALLED DUMB STARBUCKS.
- THAT LOOKS EXACTLY
LIKE A STARBUCKS.
THE LOGO, THE LETTERING,
THE GREEN COLORING--
HOW DO THEY GET AWAY
WITH THIS?
- BECAUSE THEY PUT THE WORD
"DUMB" ON TOP OF STARBUCKS,
SO THEY'RE PARODYING
STARBUCKS.
- A COFFEE CHAIN NOTORIOUS
FOR SUING IMITATORS
MAY HAVE FINALLY
MET IT'S MATCH.
- AT THE COUNTER, CUSTOMERS
CAN ORDER A "DUMB VENTI"
OR BUY A CD
OF "DUMB NORAH JONES DUETS."
- SOME PEOPLE WAITED IN LINE
FOR UP TO AN HOUR.
- IT'S AN ART GALLERY WHERE
COFFEE IS CONSIDERED ART.
- WHAT'S THE POINT OF THE ART?
I MEAN, WHAT'S THE MESSAGE?
- I DON'T KNOW.
- [speaking Spanish]
- [speaking Korean]
- I WAS STUNNED.
WE HAD MORE CUSTOMERS
THAN I EVER DREAMED OF.
AND WITHIN 24 HOURS,
DUMB STARBUCKS
HAD BECOME
A WORLDWIDE SENSATION.
- YEAH, THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
ARTISTIC VALUE HERE.
- TO ME, THIS IS A PROTEST.
THIS IS A PROTEST
AGAINST THE BIG FISH.
THE LEVIATHANS OF STARBUCKS.
- IT WAS COOL THAT PEOPLE
COULD DRAW THEIR OWN MEANING
FROM A BUSINESS THAT
WAS JUST THERE TO MAKE MONEY.
- THERE'S A RUMOR
THAT IT MIGHT BE BANKSY
AND WE'RE ALL REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT.
- I HAD INADVERTENTLY
CREATED SOMETHING
THAT WAS ON PAR WITH ONE OF
THE WORLD'S GREATEST ARTISTS.
- SOMETHING TIED TO AN ART
INSTALLATION.
MAYBE THIS IS BANKSY.
- BEFORE I KNEW IT,
CUPS FROM MY SHOP
WERE SELLING ON EBAY
FOR $500 A PIECE.
AND SWINDLERS WERE EVEN TRYING
TO CASH IN ON THE HYPE
BY HOCKING FAKE MERCHANDISE
OUTSIDE THE STORE.
BY THE END OF THE WEEKEND
I REALIZED THAT DUMB STARBUCKS
WAS A BIGGER IDEA
THAN I EVER THOUGHT IT COULD BE.
SO I GATHERED THE WORLDWIDE
MEDIA TO ANNOUNCE
THAT WE WERE EXPANDING.
[cheers and applause]
HI.
I'M PROUD TO ANNOUNCE
THAT WE'LL SOON BE OPENING
A SECOND DUMB STARBUCKS LOCATION
IN BROOKLYN, NEW YORK,
WITHIN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS.
[cheers and applause]
MY BUSINESS WAS NOT ONLY
A BONA FIDE SUCCESS,
BUT FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN MY LIFE
IT FELT LIKE PEOPLE ACTUALLY
WANTED TO BE AROUND ME.
WHATEVER I HAD DONE
RESONATED WITH THE ENTIRE WORLD.
AND THE ATTENTION
WAS LIKE SUNLIGHT ON MY SOUL.
MY ENTIRE MARKETING PLAN
DEPENDED ON USING
THEIR CORPORATE LOGO
TO GET ATTENTION.
AND THE ONLY WAY TO LEGALLY DO
IT IS BY USING "DUMB."
- EVERY MAJOR NETWORK IN AMERICA
WANTED TO KNOW MY STORY.
- NATHAN FIELDER.
- I WAS INVINCIBLE.
AND I HAVE TO ADMIT, THE VIEW
FROM THE TOP WAS PRETTY NICE.
WE'RE ALSO FAMOUS
FOR OUR PASTRIES.
I BROUGHT YOU SOME, ACTUALLY.
- OH, OKAY. YEAH, GREAT.
- I BROUGHT SOME
OF OUR PASTRIES, YEAH.
- OH, THOSE LOOK GREAT.
[audience laughs]
WHAT DO YOU CALL THESE?
ARE THESE THOSE--
- I BROUGHT MUFFINS TOO.
- OH, LOOK AT THAT.
- THESE ARE OUR FAMOUS PASTRIES.
- ISN'T THAT WEIRD.
IT SAYS VONS ON THE SIDE.
[audience laughs]
- I WAS ALL SMILES
AND MY HEAD WAS IN THE CLOUDS.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN,
REALITY HIT.